- I hired a professional
celebrity personal assistant.
Hi I'm Kane, and I've always wanted
to have a personal assistant.
This week I finally get the chance.
It is really hard to get the
little things done at home.
So many things that
I'm procrastinating on.
I'm excited for this to change my life,
so I can be a proper adult.
So I contacted Pocketbook Agency.
- The Pocketbook Agency is a corporate
and domestic staffing agency.
And we serve everybody from
founders, co-founders, CEOs.
We run the gamut from
working with regular families
and celebrities across the nation.
- They're gonna connect me
with someone who can help
me best with my needs.
(upbeat music)
- My name's Kevin, and
I'm a personal assistant.
- I'm afraid that I'll be a mean boss.
I won't have anything for them to do.
I'll have too much for them to do.
- Personal assistants do a
variety of different things.
Go pick up your car, put
gas in the car for you.
Go to the grocery store,
answer your phone for you.
The list goes on and on.
Nothing is ever too big or too small.
Celebrities tend to hire
people that are 24/7.
- I'm a little interested to see
Hhow much he really needs
a personal assistant for
'cause I don't know if it's that much.
- We'll see how this week goes.
(upbeat music)
- Day one, took me over to his house.
I met his dog Marty.
Got the run down on how
to take care of Marty.
- Did have a nice lunch,
and we got to chat and talk
about our hopes and dreams.
- The more I know whom I'm working for
the quicker I can just get things done
five steps ahead of them.
- Got a chance to bond before
all the tasks actually start.
- Kane's really cool.
Super nice, super easy to work for.
- So I bought this iMac five years ago,
and since working at Buzzfeed
we have a laptop, so I don't need it.
It's just sitting there gathering dust.
I just have no idea where to sell it,
how much it's worth, or I have the
time or energy to sell it.
- My goal is to get this
at the best price possible.
I'm gonna try to do it on Craigslist.
If that doesn't work, I'll
take to like a Mac resell.
He said the lowest he would go was $800,
but honestly I really
want to get $1,500 for it.
Because I want to impress.
- So there are these really,
really comfortable shoes
called Allbirds, and I've been
wanting them for a long time.
I just don't know where
or how to get them.
Hopefully Kevin can help me figure it out.
- I reached out to them,
and they don't have stores here.
They only have two stores,
one in San Francisco, and one in New York.
I'm probably not going
to be able to get it
unless it's shipped to us.
To have it shipped next
day could be really costly.
- So it's the end of day one.
No tasks have actually been completed yet.
I think a lot of it was just
Kevin getting to know my life.
- Today is day two.
A lot of us personal assistants,
sometimes we have the craziest
things to do for our clients.
So I'm waiting for Kane
to think of something like that.
- So I have a beautiful dog named Marty
and you might have seen
him in a few videos before.
Having a dog is great but
it's like having a child.
There are so many responsibilities.
Marty is due for a grooming
and I've been meaning
to take him to a place that babysits dogs
when you're out of town, but it takes
an hour for an evaluation.
This sounds like the perfect
task for a personal assistant.
- There's Marty, oh my God so cute.
We're going to get Marty
evaluated for daycare.
He's a little nervous.
They won't let me in the
room because they don't
want him getting distracted.
But I'm going to stay,
he's a little scared.
- Wags and Walks lets you foster dogs.
We've kept the cage
because we didn't have time
to go return it.
Right now, it's just
sitting near our toilet.
Little things like that,
that you don't really think of
is gonna be really helpful.
- So I'm here in West
LA at Wags and Walks.
Kane wanted me to deliver these crates.
And we are back at Healthy
Spot picking up Marty.
I think it's pretty evident that
this one had a long day at the daycare.
- Marty is so clean and smells so nice
and I didn't have to do a thing.
How are these things happening magically?
This is amazing, my life has changed.
We're talking about end of the week
thank you, appreciation party
for my team and people on my floor.
So I've always wanted to
have this really nice party
for my coworkers to thank them
for being so hardworking, supportive,
basically the best people ever.
Since I have Kevin, why not
end this week with a bang?
I want Kevin to put together
the best badass party he can
and help my coworkers feel appreciated.
Kevin's planned parties before.
- Our plans were team color balloons,
food, oh, and a cake.
Today's day three, going
over to Kane's house.
- It's been a few days.
Kevin hasn't sold the iMac yet.
- When you work for a big celebrity,
if they say, "Hey, I need
you to sell this iMac."
They don't typically
have this grand number
that they wanna get for it.
In Kane's situation, it
makes it a little bit harder
to do the job.
- At this point, I just
want him to get rid of it.
I just want my money and
it off my kitchen counter.
- Right now, I'm gonna meet
the guy buying his computer.
It's a success.
(Marty barks)
800.
- Whoo.
- Yeah, he sold my
iMac, $800 in my pocket.
Finally, this thing is out of my mind,
out of my sight.
It's just been taking up so
much physical and mental space
and now it's cold hard cash.
Our office allows dogs,
but I don't bring Marty as much as I want,
because every time I have a meeting,
I have to find somebody to watch Marty.
Since Kevin's here, I can take Marty
and he can come hang out.
- [Kevin] The Pocketbook Agency,
they came in and they did their little
segment interview for the video.
He wants me to remind him
every two hours to drink water.
- So for some reason, I always forget
to drink water and I
get really dehydrated.
I get headaches and I get tired
and I'm not able to perform my job
the best way I can.
- They don't always have time
to be remembering to
literally drink water,
they're so busy, so sometimes assistants
have to be that person to
remind them those things.
- I'm also constantly thinking
if a task is too beneath him.
What if he thinks reminding
me about water is annoying?
What if he thinks I'm annoying?
I'm not used to having
a personal assistant
to just do all these little things for me.
- Kane has been really
awesome to work with.
I just told him, I was like,
if I could, I'd work for you
'cause you're a really cool guy.
Wanna go pick up some things for the party
to be more prepared for tomorrow.
Also, I have to go do
some shopping for him.
Today, I need to remind him
every two hours to drink water.
Kane wants a new pair of jeans.
Gotta be resourceful as
a personal assistant.
You can't just go to the store,
because they didn't have
the ones that he wanted,
and say, "Oh they don't have it."
I decided I would FaceTime him
and we ended up getting
a bomb pair of jeans.
Sometimes, you end up
learning a little bit
from the principal.
Kane took me up to the roof.
- So one of the nice things
about having a personal assistant
is having someone to
take Instagram photos.
So we went on the roof and had a fun time
taking photos for each other
and I got to teach him a few tips
that I've learned from past videos
and I let him borrow my jacket
and it was a fun time.
- So he taught me how to
take an Instagram photo.
He does this one two three,
and he takes a picture, one two three.
- He seemed really thankful and happy
to learn some tips that maybe
he never really knew before.
So Kevin started on Monday,
and today is Thursday,
and the shoes arrived,
and I am super excited.
I saw these on Instagram.
(angelic music)
(upbeat music)
- So it's 2:30 and I can't sleep
because of this party.
This is one thing you wanna get perfect.
I'm gonna do my best to go back to sleep.
It's day five, the final day.
- Today is the day of the big party
and at the same time, I
have a big shoot going on.
Pretty far away from where Kevin
is setting up for the party.
I'm not worried, I have
full faith in Kevin.
He's pulled off all the tasks so far
and I wish him luck.
- So I'm in the stairwell.
I'm looking for Kane 'cause
he's not answering his phone.
- When I'm directing a
shoot, I'm fully focused
and totally off the grid.
- I need to find out if he
has these jugs for the punch.
And there's a couple other
things I need to talk
to him about, and I just tripped
and I think I probably sprained my ankle.
The show must go on.
We got an hour and 50
minutes before the party.
I got the balloons.
I'm gonna head over to
Gelson's to pick up the cake,
order the food, things are looking good.
- Kevin texted me and said he tripped.
He says he's gonna continue
to finish setting up
for the party, and I
really hope he's okay.
So I just ran over from my shoot
and this looks beautiful, holy crap.
I was blown away, there were balloons,
there was cake, there was food,
and I was so impressed by Kevin.
He was able to push through
even though he had an incident.
Mad respect for that.
With my busy schedule and
the schedule that we have
at Buzzfeed, we would never have time
to do something like this.
Kevin was able to put it together.
So after checking everything out,
it was time to invite my
coworkers to the party.
He pulled it off to the T.
- Yeah, this is very impressive.
- This is so nice.
I'm so, this is so great, Kane, thank you.
- I'm in love with this.
When you said food, I
didn't expect real food.
- Such a lovely Friday surprise.
- [Kane] Kevin did an amazing job.
- I'm shocked, this nice
stuff never happens.
I am so grateful.
- Thank you.
- Phenomenal person.
- I'm proud, Kevin is proud.
Party was a success.
So after the party, we tried to make sure
that Kevin was okay, and so
we took him to urgent care
to get him checked out
to make sure everything was all good.
That was a wild end to a week.
I was not expecting I'd
end up in urgent care.
The doctor took x-rays and made sure
that nothing was broken.
It's a sprain and he'll heal back
in a few days to a week.
Thank you so much for your help this week.
- Of course, it was a pleasure.
Kane is a good employer.
He's really easy, a lot
easier than other people
I've worked for, I really like Buzzfeed.
Buzzfeed rocks.
- You know the list of
things that you have to do
all the way in the back of your mind
that you never get around to doing?
This week, I got them all done
thanks to my personal assistant, Kevin.
One day, I would love to
have a personal assistant,
but right now, I don't have enough things
for them to do and also, I'm nowhere near
being able to afford one.
But hopefully one day.
(upbeat music)